비용 함수를 찾는 것뿐이었어요. 이 연산자의 각 반복을 레이어라고 불러요. 이 레이어들은
앞서 설명한 것처럼 시스템의 시간 진화를 이산화한 것으로 볼 수 있어요. 교대 패턴은
트로터 분해에서 나오고, 일반적으로 비가환 행렬의 지수 함수를 근사해요. 일반적으로 레이어나
스텝이 많을수록 연속적인 시간 진화에 더 가까워져요. 이론적으로는 결과가 더 정확해지는 거죠.
하지만 이 예시에서는 두 레이어로 샘플링을 시작할 거예요. 비용 함수 해밀토니안과
믹서 모두 파라미터화되어 있다는 걸 기억하세요. 아직 gamma와
beta의 최적값을 찾아야 해요. 정보가 정말 많았다는 거 알아요. 이런 종류의 수학을 처음 보신다면 어려울 수 있어요. 다행히 Qiskit의
멋진 점 중 하나는 방금 설명한 내용의 많은 부분이 사용자의 큰 수고 없이 자동으로 처리될 수 있다는 거예요.
내부적으로 무슨 일이 일어나는지 이해하는 게 좋긴 해요. 특히 더 큰 실험으로 확장할 때요. 하지만 매번 이 모든 작업을
직접 할 필요는 없어요. 이제 문제를 양자 circuit에 매핑했어요. 꽤 많은 작업이었지만
걱정 마세요. 할수록 더 쉬워지고 직관적이 돼요. 이제 2단계인
하드웨어에 맞게 circuit 최적화로 넘어갈 준비가 됐어요. 방금 만든 circuit이 꽤 단순해 보이고
직관적 이해를 쌓는 데 유용하지만, 양자 칩이 이 추상화된
블록을 이해하지 못한다는 걸 기억하세요. 하드웨어에 기본으로 있는 1-qubit 및 2-qubit gate의 연속으로 변환해야 해요. 여기서
"기본"이라는 말은 qubit에서 직접 수행할 수 있는 형태로 재구성된다는 의미예요. 그런 circuit들은
backend의 명령어 집합 아키텍처, 줄여서 ISA circuit으로 쓰인다고 해요.
Qiskit SDK의 transpiler 모듈은 다양한
circuit 변환을 수행할 수 있는 일련의 transpilation 패스를 제공해요. circuit이 우리 목적에 맞게
최적화되어 있는지 확인하고 싶어요. 이전 강의에서 transpilation 과정에 여러 단계가 포함된다는 걸 떠올려 보세요.
circuit의 qubit, 즉 결정 변수를 디바이스의 물리적 qubit에 매핑하고,
양자 circuit의 명령어를 backend가 실제로 이해하는 하드웨어 기본 명령어로 언롤링하고,
circuit에서 직접 상호작용하는 qubit들을 서로 인접한 물리적 qubit들로
라우팅하는 단계들이에요. 항상 그렇듯, 더 자세한 내용은 문서에서 찾을 수 있어요.
이제 어떤 backend에서 circuit을 실행할지 선택하는 흥미로운 단계가 왔어요. 실제로 이 과정을
transpilation 단계 전에 해야 해요. transpiler가 프로세서에 따라 다르게 최적화하기 때문이에요. 이게 Qiskit이 이 단계의 많은 부분을
자동화할 수 있다는 게 중요한 또 다른 이유예요. circuit을 직접 손으로 최적화하고 싶지 않으실 거예요.
가능하긴 하지만 때로는 까다롭고 시간이 많이 걸려요. 결국 다른 속성을 가진
다른 프로세서에서 circuit을 실행하고 싶다는 걸 깨닫고 모든 작업을 다시 해야 할 수도 있으니까요. 선택한
backend를 transpiler 함수에 넘기고 최적화 수준을 지정하는 걸 잊지 마세요.
이번에는 가장 높고 가장 철저한 최적화인 최적화 레벨 3을 선택했어요.
2단계는 그게 전부예요. circuit이 자동으로 transpile되었고, 1-qubit 및 2-qubit gate로
어떻게 변환되었는지 볼 수 있도록 여기에 그려봤어요. 이제 3단계인
Qiskit Primitives로 circuit 실행할 시간이에요. 지금까지 gamma와 beta 파라미터를
그대로 둔 채 circuit을 transpile했어요. 하지만 이 파라미터 값을 지정하지 않고는 circuit을 실제로 실행할 수 없어요. QAOA
워크플로우에서 최적의 QAOA 파라미터는 반복적인 최적화 루프에서 찾아요. 일련의 circuit
평가를 실행하고 고전 최적화기를 사용해서 최적의 beta와 gamma 파라미터를 찾는 거예요. 하지만 어딘가에서
시작해야 하니까, Gamma 1, Gamma 2에는 π/2, Beta 1, Beta 2에는 π를
초기 추정값으로 설정했어요. 또한, gamma와 beta의 더 좋은 해를 찾기 위해 최적화기를 사용할 거라는 점도
알아두세요. 지금은 두 레이어만 계산하고 있어서 그게 전부지만, 더 정확한 QAOA circuit을 만든다면
레이어를 더 추가하게 될 거고, 그러면 각 순차적
레이어마다 최적화된 gamma와 beta가 필요해요. 잠깐 멈춰서 Primitives 옵션을 떠올려볼게요. estimator와
sampler가 있어요. 이런 종류의 작업에 어떤 걸 사용할 것 같으세요? 어떤 걸 생각하셨든
사실 둘 다 맞아요. estimator와 sampler 모두 사용할 거거든요. 초기 최적화
루프에는 estimator가 필요하지만, 나중에 최종
해를 읽어내는 데는 sampler를 사용할 거예요. 이제 알고리즘을 실행할 준비가 거의 다 됐어요, 정말이에요. 하지만 아주 빠르게, 작업을
다양한 방식으로 보낼 수 있다는 걸 짚고 넘어가야 해요. 이걸 실행 모드라고 해요. 먼저 job 모드는
context manager 없이 만든 estimator나 sampler의 단일 primitive 요청이에요. circuit과 입력은 primitive
통합 블록, 즉 PUB로 패키징되어 양자
컴퓨터의 실행 태스크로 제출돼요. batch 모드는 독립적인 여러 job으로 구성된 실험을 효율적으로 실행하기 위한 다중 job 관리자예요.
여러 primitive job을 동시에 제출하려면 batch 모드를 사용하세요. session 모드는 다중 job 워크로드를 실행하기 위한 전용
윈도우예요. 프리미엄 사용자가 변분 알고리즘을 더 예측 가능한 방식으로 실험하고
스택의 병렬성을 활용해서 여러 실험을 동시에 실행할 수도 있어요.
반복적인 워크플로우와 전용 접근이 필요한 실험에는 session을 사용하세요. QAOA 실험의 경우,
접근 권한이 있다면 session이 좋은 선택이에요. beta와
gamma의 여러 값에 대해 여러 circuit을 시도해야 하기 때문이에요. 이제 최적화 문제로 돌아가 봐요. 이미
비용 함수 해밀토니안 HC를 정의했고, 전체 워크플로우는 이래요. QAOA
알고리즘은 중첩 상태의 qubit을 초기화하고 P 레이어로 ansatz를 적용해요.
gamma와 beta 파라미터를 초기화한 다음 estimator primitive를 사용해서 circuit을 실행해요.
기댓값을 계산하면 COBYLA라는 SciPy 최적화기를 사용할 거예요. COBYLA는
QPU 외부에서 고전적으로 비용 함수를 최적화해요. gamma와 beta 값이 업데이트되면
반복해요. 전체 비용 함수의 값이 수렴해서 최솟값에 도달할 때까지 이걸 반복할 거예요.